un convoi encore déraillé aujourd'hui on
ne compte heureusement que quatre
blessés légers
c'est décidé le val le métro de lille
circulera en 88 entre la ville et
l'aéroport de chicago
les lycéens de la rentrée ont été sondés
ils sont à l'opposé de leurs aînés dont
agnès varda reçoit le lion d'or pur sans
toit ni loi depardieu sacré meilleur
acteur
madame monsieur bonsoir un train de la
sncf a donc encore déraillé aujourd'hui
cela s'est passé vers 12h30 sur la ligne
nancy thionville
heureusement il n'ya pas eu de blessés
graves quatre personnes sont légèrement
atteintes mais un train qui déraille
pour la seconde fois en moins d'une
semaine et pour la quatrième fois depuis
le début de l'été ça fait beaucoup
d'autant que c'est le même scénario qui
s'est reproduit un tronçon limité à 30
km/heure sur lequel le conducteur de la
motrice avait lancé sa machine à 120
km/heure gérard pinson sur cette ligne
nancy thionville qui irrigue la lorraine
du nord au sud des trains comme celui ci
baptisée métro leur circulent à longueur
de journée dans les deux sens à hauteur
de novaes en moselle des travaux
obligent actuellement la circulation
montante a utilisé une déviation sur
celle ci la vitesse était limitée à 70
km/heure et à la proche de l'aiguillage
à 30 km heure
malgré toutes ces consignes de sécurité
expressément notifié aux conducteurs
c'est beaucoup trop vite que ce midi
sept rames de 3 voitures
c'est donc présenter en gare de novaes
ans
m alors dans six thionville qui passait
à neuf et en vers 12h30 à aborder à 120
à l'heure un aiguillage qu'il aurait dû
franchir à 30 kilomètres à l'heure tout
se dérègle
alors qui est fautif dans cette affaire
on peut penser que le mécanicien n'a pas
observé la signalisation et les ordres
qu'il avait reçu au départ du 200 dépôts
avant d'être interrogé par les gendarmes
de metz le conducteur fautif légèrement
blessé est actuellement entendu par les
responsables de la sncf âgé de 41 ans et
agents du dépôt de thionville
connaissait bien la ligne même s'il
n'était rentré de vacances qui hier
jeudi son erreur est difficilement
explicable
heureusement parmi les 60 voyageurs
trois seulement ont été légèrement
blessés et n'aurait ans ne prendra pas
la suite d'argenton sur creuse et de
flaujac dans la liste des catastrophes
ferroviaires
toujours est il que ce soir les
syndicats cfdt cgt de cheminots exige
plus encore qu'hier des efforts en
matière de sécurité et notamment la
présence de deux agents dans les
motrices le val a gagné la partie
aujourd'hui à chicago
le métro automatique fabriqués par matra
en effet été choisi pour assurer la
desserte de l'aéroport de la ville
le plus important du monde leval il
fonctionne déjà à lille depuis deux ans
matra remporté ce marché d'un milliard
de francs à l'issue d'une lutte acharnée
face à des concurrents américains
difficile hubert coudurier à lille où
ils transportent cent mille personnes
par jour le vin l'a fait la preuve de
ses atouts tout d'abord sont moindres
coûts de fonctionnement car c'est un
véhicule entièrement automatisé ce qui
permet une plus grande rotation des
navettes et augmente la sécurité c'est
aussi un système de transport léger qui
s'adapte au terrain pour la desserte de
l'aéroport de chicago le plus fort
trafic du monde
il sera modifié en une version plus
large ne comprenant qu'une seule rame au
lieu de deux
la municipalité de chicago a donc
finalement opté pour l'offre de matra
après l'avoir écarté dans un premier
temps au profit de westinghouse
plusieurs entreprises américaines seront
néanmoins associés à ce contrat de plus
de 100 millions de dollars
mais il permet à la firme française d'
obtenir l'indispensable référence à
l'étranger qui lui manquait après le
choix tout récent de la municipalité de
toulouse
de plus ce succès pourrait appeler
d'autres commandes sur le vaste marché
nord américain
en france d'autres municipalités
semblent intéresser particulièrement
strasbourg
des négociations sont par ailleurs
menées avec la suisse pour l'aéroport de
genève ainsi qu'avec plusieurs pays du
sud est asiatique
un investissement global qui s'étale en
général sur plusieurs années et dont
matra commence aujourd'hui à recueillir
les fruits le val est désormais une
technique de pointe qui dispose d'un
passeport pour l'exportation restent à
la rentabiliser en afrique du sud
monseigneur tutu s'en prend au président
reagan l'évêque sud-africain se demande
si le président américain n'est pas
crypto raciste le prélat anglican note
que l'antipathie du président pour les
sanctions à l'égard de l'afrique du sud
ne l'empêchent pas d'user de cette
stratégie contre la pologne et le
nicaragua par exemple pendant ce temps
la tension persiste dans les quartiers
métis au cap et les blancs sont de plus
en plus nombreux à se procurer des armes
à feu le fait que la zone des émeutes se
déplace vers leur quartier constitue un
tournant
gilles du jonchay nous explique le
pourquoi et le comment de cette
évolution
c'est la violente répression il ya dix
jours de la marche pacifique en faveur
du leader noir emprisonnés nelson
mandela et l'arrestation la veille du
pasteur beaussac organisateurs de la
marche qui a mis le feu aux poudres dans
toute la péninsule du cap
le révérend allan boesak 39 ans est en
effet le président du front démocratique
uni ce mouvement anti apartheid créé il
ya deux ans qui a pris la tête en
septembre 84 de la révolte dans les
cités noir d'afrique du sud
le surcroît cette un métis de mitchell
se plaignent près du cap et les métis
sont extrêmement nombreux dans cette
région
puisqu'un seul ils forment plus de la
moitié de la population il n'en fallait
pas plus pour que leurs jeunes éléments
qui jusqu'à présent se contenter de
boycotter les cours dans leur école se
mobilisent à leur tour aux côtés des
noirs pour s'en prendre désormais à tout
ce qui symbolise le pouvoir parle depuis
le 29 août dans les banlieues métis du
cap
les violences n'ont guère cessé mais les
métis à la différence des noirs vivent
dans des quartiers situés tout près des
zones blanches inévitablement ces
dernières allaient donc être
touché par les émeutes c'est ce qui
s'est passé mercredi soir quand 150
métis armés de cocktails molotov ont
envahi la zone résidentielle de cry
fountain les blancs du quartier ont
alors riposté avec des armes à feu
faisant selon la police deux blessés
mais selon l'agent sa société de presse
de mort c'était la première fois dans
l'histoire mouvementée de l'afrique du
sud qu un quartier blanc était touché
par des émeutes raciales en france la
rentrée scolaire est donc prévue pour
lundi
les enseignants en grande partie pris
possession de leur lieu de travail
aujourd'hui et pendant ce temps les
journalistes demandent aux instituts de
sondage de les éclairer les éclairer sur
cette population icn le point et
phosphore publie quelques révélations
qui tente tout vers cette conclusion les
lycéens de 85 n'ont plus rien à voir
avec leurs aînés de 75
il se rapprocherait plutôt de ceux de 65
ainsi à 80% ils sont satisfaits de leur
professeur ils les trouvent compétents
ils les veulent efficace en échange de
quoi ils les respectent les lycéens à 85
veulent réussir avant tout sur le
terrain jean luc mertens a pu constater
que la réalité recoupaient bien souvent
les enseignements des sondages paris may
moi personnellement le bac je condamne
en tant que forme de sélection cette
année ils vont plus précisément nous
attaquer les problèmes revendicatif
entre guillemets comme la sélection
sociale
le baccalauréat rouler politiser ces
problèmes effectivement mais parce
qu'ils sont politiques personnellement
au niveau des études au buzzer de fin se
font pas le terme de révolution
révolutionna risée tous à septembre à
85,1 lycées parmi d'autres
au bout du compte je répète il ya le bac
il faut la voir
et c'est là pour ça comme non seulement
il ya la crise il faut y arriver encore
mieux que si que si la situation et
c'est vous pourrez dire normal le but
essentiel est bien d'arriver à entrer
dans la vie active dans les meilleures
conditions possibles c'est bien évident
si c'est un peu chacun pour sa poire
1969 1985 15 ans les lycées sont les
mêmes et pourtant rien n'est plus
vraiment comme avant
en fait nous le changement que je
perçois depuis 15 ans c'est un
changement un petit peu de la demande
il y avait une demande très collective
après les années 70 72 c'est à dire que
tout passait par des porte parole des
réunions des discussions à l'intérieur
de la classe et j'ai l'impression que
les demandes des élèves sont beaucoup
plus individualisée à l'heure actuelle
les phénomène qu'on observe en ce moment
dans les sondages français il faut un
analogue à ce qu on observerait dans des
pays étrangers où l'environnement socio
économique n'est pas tout à fait
identique lorsque je crois c'est qu'on
assiste là à un mouvement de
modifications qui nous concerne pas
uniquement les lycéens français et qui
n'est pas nécessairement liée à une
conjoncture immédiate je crois que c'est
un phénomène de fond beaucoup plus
important premier bénéficiaire du
phénomène
les profs mais à une condition qu'il
soit bon j'ai peur qu'il soit mauvais
qui
qu'il me donne pas ce que j'attends lui
de gâcher une année dans une matière
c'est ça m'angoisse fait respecter
apprécié par une large majorité d'élèves
les profs se sont ils pour autant
rassurer je vais pas être ni rassuré ni
ni pas rassuré mais par contre je suis
assez satisfait oui c'est au niveau si
vous voulez de l'opinion publique c'est
à dire que l'année dernière il y avait
toute une campagne de presse contre les
les privilégiés l'enseignement bon ben
là on n'en parle plus de privilèges de
nombreux villages on parle simplement de
bons de gens qui font honnêtement leur
boulot je crois que c'est quand même une
approche beaucoup plus sereine que celle
de l'année dernière alors enterré la
contestation on pourrait le penser mais
l'histoire si elle ne se répète jamais
deux fois de la même façon nous habitue
à la prudence
après tout personne n'avait prévu 68
après laurent fabius après raymond barre
michel rocard a marqué aujourd'hui de sa
pierre la semaine politique michel
rocard qui tenait aux arcs sa station
préférée sa station de ski préférée
l'université d'été des jeunes rocardien
il a écarté très clairement l'hypothèse
d'une rupture de sa part et le parti
socialiste et il a déploré le temps
actuel du débat politique daniel
sportiello n'allez surtout pas imaginer
que michel rocard ait décidé de répondre
à laurent fabius au cours de
l'université d'été des jeunes rocardien
il n'a pas regardé l'heure de vérité
ils étaient retenus ce soir là s'est il
borné à déclaré au forum des rocardiens
qui soit dit en passant se tenait aux
arcs
aux mêmes dates que l'université d'été
des jeunes socialistes à montpellier et
ce ne sont pas les jeunes rocardien qui
reprocheront à l'ancien ministre de
l'agriculture de jouer sa propre carte
de présidentiable une carte que michel
rocard entend bien jouer d'ailleurs au
sein du parti socialiste
hors du parti point de salut michel
rocard le sait bien mais ce qui est
nouveau c'est qu'il ait décidé de le
dire devant un micro toujours fidèle à
son parler vrai enfin
que pour être candidat ou non à gauche
la dernière des folies que d'ouvrir la
guerre avec le parti politique on voit
d'autre part construire un nouveau parti
politique ça prend en moyenne une
vingtaine d'années historiquement je ne
vois pas la majorité du parti prenant
leurs responsabilités fantastique de
nous chasser
mais des nervosités des petites erreurs
mais cela est absurde dont je les dis
fermement simplement pour éviter que des
camarades sauver s'inquiéter la france
est généralement gâtés au festival de
venise
mais aujourd'hui on peut dire sans
exagération qu'elle est comblé le lion
d'or la récompense suprême est attribué
à inès varda pour son nouveau film sans
toit ni loi
le lion d'argent et qu'on pense de ce
film franco-belge coproduit par fr3
gérard depardieu qui en est déclarée
tout est beau dit a reçu le prix
d'interprétation pour son rôle dans
polisse le film de maurice pialat et
comme si tout cela ne suffisait pas le
jury de la mostra a souligné
l'excellente interprétation de jane
birkin et celle de sandrine bonnaire
nous les découvrons dans ce film d'agnès
varda dormait dehors tout seul ouais
c'est passe pas on n'avait pas le choix
c'est ça
n'avait pas de maison bah ouais c'est ça
la famille ouellet patron
je vous invite avec mes questions
un peu ça va tous les chauffeurs par le
stoppeur des fois je manque des
conneries parce qu'une invention pas de
famille pas de maisons salon
henry chapier vous nous arrivait de
venise alors en quoi ce film est-il
différent ce film d'agnès varda des
autres films qui concouraient pour le
lion d'or et par voie de conséquence
pour quelle raison at il été primés mais
moi je crois que qu'un film d'agnès
varda ne ressemble à rien tout
simplement à rien de ce qu'on connaît
évidemment la passion qu'on peut avoir
pour allier sarda d'apt depuis 15 ans à
peu près elle est évidemment moins connu
que truffaut et godard est toutefois
extrêmement aimé par les jeunes
générations parce qu'elle parle vrai et
aussi parce qu'elle traite d'un thème
qui est cher un peu à tout le monde
comment être libre comment vivre libres
jusqu'à quel point vivre libre
n'implique pas au fond un immense
renoncement parce que l'héroïne en
question qu'on aperçoit au volant de la
voiture de macha méril sandrine bonnaire
son personnage et bien finalement elle
meurt de froid
c'est un peu une allégorie bien sûr
cette vie de bohème et bien là des
conséquences voilà mais si vous voulez
ça c'est la récompense suprême comme
vous l'avez dit mais non à venise il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses et
quelque chose de plus générale et de
très important quand même je crois le
triomphe de la france à la mostra mme
n'est pas le fruit du hasard
il résulte d'une politique volontariste
qui engage gros moyens financiers en
faveur des auteurs qu'ils soient
français ou étrangers à venise jack lang
et danielle mitterrand sont venus
célébrer l'union sacrée des créateurs
européens face à la compétition acharnée
que leur livrent les séries américaines
mais l'enthousiasmé gagne-t-il et
d'acteur essentiel dans ce combat gérard
depardieu a été sacré comme le meilleur
j'aime bien que les gens se penchent
vers des histoires de coeur et d'âme ou
qui sont qui paraissent maintenant à
notre époque ça tout ça par démodé mais
j'aime le coup de foudre
et bien ce coup de foudre le jury du
festival l'a entièrement partagé avec
lui
henry voudra n'a plus grand chose à voir
d'ailleurs avec le cinéma où ça il ya
quelqu'un qui a dû fuir le festival
devenir une petite idée de qui ça peut
être c'est pas caroline de monaco pas
hasard rôle a poursuivi pouvait pas
tomber très loin en fait c'est ira
furstenberg poursuivie par les paparazzi
la princesse que la presse du coeur
justement n'avait pas hésité à marier
prochainement la semaine dernière avec
le prince rainier de monaco est bien la
princesse s'est réfugié à milan et puis
elle a démenti la nouvelle confirmant
ainsi le précédent démenti du bureau de
presse de la principauté à flushing
meadow les français viennent d'être
battus en finale du double noah et
leconte ont dû s'incliner en quatre sets
un incident à la fin du troisième set
vous voyez sur ces images le premier set
un incident dû à une faute d'arbitrage
les a sans doute sérieusement
défavorisés la dernière étape de la
course de l'europe est parti de toulon à
la mi-journée en ce moment les voiliers
met le cap sur porto de charvaux au nord
de la sardaigne
un avis de coup de vent est annoncé pour
la nuit mais dès le départ le spectacle
a commencé au large des côtes françaises
catamaran de philippe poupon et
légalement baptisé fleury michon a
démâté la poutre avant le flotteur
tribord ont été brisées un coup dur pour
l'un des favoris de cette course sur les
lieux de l'accident
la caméra de thalassa enregistrait pour
nous à 12 heures départ spectaculaire
dans la rade de toulon richmond fleury
michon écart cadélac dans le fond pas de
la tête suivi par jet services
filez poupon dynamisé par sa performance
lors de l'étape précédente fond sur la
première bouée de dégagement
hélas quelques minutes après cette vous
est sur le bord de près leurs émissions
des maths le spectacle est désolant
non seulement le mât est tombé mais la
poutre avant et casser ainsi que le
flotteur tribord
le catamaran vainqueur de la récente
route de la découverte gravement
endommagé termine ici sa course c'est
une usure c'est sûr parce que bateau a
tenu hier aux antilles en avait hier et
beaucoup de vent ok
partie l'usure à prévisible
une belle feinte quoi
aucune forme de ballade à responsable
on va attendre les expertises
les mâles ou quoi
le grand catamaran de philippe poupon
été remorqué vers le port de toulon
débarrassé de son gréement image
poignante d'un rêve cassé oui pour les
autres les premières arrivées sont
prévues au petit matin peut-être même en
fin de nuit si le vent forcit puisqu'un
mistral sur terre est en train de
souffler ils devraient arriver
rapidement en mer et ce mistral en
provence a attisé plusieurs incendies de
forêt sept ans tous allumés en divers
points de la côte bleue entre martigues
et marseille alors qu'il est les
sinistres ont pu être circonscrit par
les pompiers et les pilotes de canadair
cela nous amène à évoquer le temps qu'il
fera demain le soleil prédominera toute
la journée dans le midi le mistral
faiblira en matinée les températures
seront en baisse par rapport à celle
d'aujourd'hui
le dollar il a gagné 20 centimes à paris
au cours de la journée cette flambée ne
devrait paraître démenti avant plusieurs
jours
à la bourse de paris la morosité des
jours précédents s'est un peu estompée
mais les affaires ne sont vraiment pas
bonnes et oui ça semble bien parti pour
le donneur qui gagnaient plus de 20
points ce matin à paris hier annonces de
ventes automobiles record aux etats-unis
et cet après midi une baisse du chômage
du coup un vent d'optimisme souffle sur
les cambistes qui anticipent largement
une reprise de la croissance américaine
au second semestre
par contre la bourse de paris terminé la
semaine dans un climat de morosité si
quelques valeurs se sont ressaisis dans
l'ensemble les échanges étaient très
modéré les investisseurs semblent faire
une pause dans l'attende des traits
prochaine introduction sur le second
marché fin de semaine hésitante à wall
street
car si le marché a été quelque peu
entraîné par la hausse du dollar par
contre il craint une tension sur les
taux d'intérêt américains alors une
tendance devrait se dégager plus
nettement en début de semaine prochaine
et c'est sur cette nouvelle que nous
allons nous séparer demain soir 3 et à
22 heures
bonsoir le rappel des titres de cette
édition
un convoi encore déraillé aujourd'hui on
ne compte heureusement que quatre
blessés légers
c'est décidé le val le métro de lille
circulera en 88 entre la ville et
l'aéroport de chicago
michel rocard aux arcs il écarte très
clairement l'hypothèse de rupture avec
le parti socialiste
agnès varda reçoit le lion d'or pur sans
toit ni loi
depardieu sacré meilleur acteur